Hello everybody my name is Markiplier and welcome back to Unforgiving: A Northern Hymn, we just, uh,
We visited the little ones.
That was nice.
Happy about that.
And, uh, we're gonna go
[monster noises]
Well apparently there's a clown that's uh, making balloon animals over there, that's nice.
The little ones are really gonna love that
So, uh, now we're gonna go...
To The Hall of the Harp,
and I don't know what goes on at "The Hall of the Harp"
But I'm pretty sure it ain't gonna be too... friendly so
Let's find out shall-
Okaaay you
Talkin' about the harp?
Now why would you hide the harp?
That's just mean.
"Belt is broken, there's a new one at the blacksmith."
Oh! Oh you mean that belt?
I think I know what of what we're talking about.
"Because of theft, the cabinet is locked.
The key is with the Guardian."
Oh you mean, that key?
Huh huh ha
Haha haaaa
Alright, wait there's another piece of paper here.
Do you need- a tongue and an eyeball because I got that!
"Start the gasoline and power first,"
All right,
Donezo wonzo.
Looks like me got the monzo, if you know what I'm talking about haha, I already got it.
[confused noises]
Wh..
[realization noises]
Okay, let me pump this a few times. Oh, yeah, let me get that gas flowin'.
Pumpity dumpity, oh yeah get that pumpage-- alright how about now?
Oh yeah, oh yeah, oh--
Oh yeah, oh yeah, oh yeah, oh yeah
Aaaaah
Now we're kicking it into high gear!
Oh yeah, oh- oh-
Oh yeah, oh now I got it. Oh. I've got it.
You ever seen how big my brain is?
You ever wondered why my head so huge?
It's because I'm really smart, okay?
Don't question it!
And I'm good at solving puzzles, so leave it at that!
It's all fact--
scientifically speaking.
Anyway, carrying on.
Don't know where I'm going, but I know what's happening.
I mean what's happening is that I'm marching towards my imminent demise, and trying to run away from the fears of--
[inhale]
My brother's death being my fault. Oh, woowoo. Oh, shut up.
Yeah, oh...
Ah.
No. Thank. You.
Okay, wow.
I--
Something tells me it's absolutely happening. You are all tree creatures, and it's just as bad as it sounds, okay.
Glad I cleared that up for you. Now, I gotta go find this harp.
Glad I've been able to see--uh.
Not again. No, no!
no no no, no no no no no, oooh, ahhh
Water
Great, ooh!
This person just planned for their house to be like this. Okay, all right good for you.
Planning for the inevitable is a... good thing I think
Okay
Who came for what now?
Okay, that's probably the Hall of the Harp, but I'm gonna see what's over here.
I think I missed the building back on the way, but I'll hit it on the way back.
Okay
Okay all right
Well, at least you acknowledge your failures.
and, uh, when you're able to reconcile with that, then you can truly make progress in life.
So you're already taking the first step, so that's good. I'm very proud of you.
That's locked.
Ahhh.
"Torvald! can't find the frame with the hidden song."
Alright.
Oooooh.
"By the roots of the trees they dwell, the three that spin the threads of life. Some call them
witches, while others claim they're fair maidens from the Giants. They who powerfully weave all of our destinies."
Cool, I guess okay.
Oooh, ah, oh..
That's terrible. Okay-- ooh, wait. I didn't even see the head poking out. That's-that's even worse.
Aah, no one did their dishes in this town. Ahh, an even better....
Chamber pot.
There's another naked lady?
"Ruth. Found. Dead."
"Body was found with the scratch marks around the face, specifically around the eyes."
Oh! Was I there? Did I do that, because I seem to have, uh, uh, an affinity for eyes.
Whoa, I heard that.
All right, I don't know what these things I'm collecting are.
This is weird.
Okay, "Borta Brah men hamma bast!" Okay, sure, we'll go with that one.
Hmm...
I don't like this at all, nothing about me likes any of what's happening in here.
There's got to be a reason for all of this,
Like who's Ruth?
And why does that matter?
An- and it seems like people would probably have more to worry about than just
a few scratch marks around your eyes if you go missing in the woods,
Hence the fact that you're kind of dead and all.
Like that whole thing-- ooh.
Hello?
Alright. It all just seems to be, uh...
Bad in this town, like no matter what way you slice it everything here seems to be... awful. In every way.
[Inhale] In every possible,
Conceivable way, so why did they stay? Why would they stay? Why would anybody stay here?
This is a terrible, terrible, terrible place to be!
Eugh
Terrible, hundred percent, awful all the way through.
One for started it indeed, okay? OOOoooh, ah is this the kettlebell studio? Good, okay greeeeat...
Excellent, one, I'm so glad I got that.
"The Key: the harp was formed from-- " oh,
I'm not even gonna try with that one "...itself, inserted with magical golden carved with holy runes.
The dwarves gave the harp to Freya, who plucked-- picked strands from her golden hair and used them as strings,
So the magic could flow through the powerful instrument."
Ooohrighty then,
I did not mean to light this, but okay, I'm gonna...
Fate has deemed it worthy.
Aaaah
What room is this, the theater room?
Greeeeat..
Sure I'm finding a lot of these things. The holy duty!
Uh..
"Ava miss you," okay, where'd- where'd Ava- where'd Ava go, huh? Did something happen to Avaaa?
Guuuuuuys
I got a bad feeling about Ava.
I don't know about you guys, but methinks Ava might be dead.
Aight what's in here?
Anything in this chest? Okay.
Oh that- oh that's- awful. If that's a face. That's awful.
Methinks it might not be a face, methinks it might be a waterfall, but it looks like the horrible face lady from
I-It. Euoh.
Do not like that. Ah! Good, okay?
It's a screaming mouth and an eye, d-don't tell me that's anything, but that it's got a bullet hole in it. I don't know why
All right, can't see anything.
Ah
That's horrible.
Okay, what do we got here?
Anything? Yeah, there we are.
Oh
To Johann Larsson
Ruth
And a Ruth
Okay, well Ruth is very dead, so we know that for a fact,
And then we can move on with our lives once we take that knowledge.
[Deep inhale] Mmmmmmh
What'sthi- "The power of Runes: Otis-
Odin sacrificed himself and suffered for knowledge about the runes -
The powerful symbols, with which humans can bend reality.
Assumed that the stones and powerful places which channel their powers can be found."
Ooookaaay
Whhyyy?
But why though? But why?
Ah yee
Alright, I'm a light another one cuz I can't see shit.
As long as everybody just stays in their place, everything's gonna be fine.
Ah yee
I'd kill to have a flashlight in this time. I gotta imagine that somebody's got a flashlight in this place--
I mean they got electricity that somehow still magically running, even though
I'm pretty sure all this place is purely run by runes and magic.
Nothing is as it seems, I imagine.
Hello, uuh- good. Ruuunes?
Are these the power runes?
Oh G- (eyes again) Uuuaaaahhh
Hate that!
Hate everything about those eyes... staring at me in these things.
As if it was waiting for me to open these drawers.
On which I bet you were. You are judging me very harshly. Is there more eyes over here?
Nooo?
Thanks, is it a mouth?
Ah, "Ruth Is Dead."
Yes, Ruth is dead indeed.
Ah, The Harp.
Just lying around, who trusts that?
Not I.
Not even a little bit.
That is not the harp. Why wo- Oh! Nice belt! This is a great belt guys!
Quality leather, alright well. That's not good.
I don't wanna. What if I don't wanna. Hmm? You ever think about that? Dick- hole... ass bag?
You ever think about that?
Uh-oh
You know, you know, I feel like we've reached an impasse here.
I've got a heart that I very much enjoy, and you've got an ass for a face. So really, who's the loser here?
I guess I gotta put it back.
All righty then, what I need--
Fire
Fire and
Bluuuoodah
So yuh- let me get this straight, you want fire and blued
I've got an eyeball and a tongue, are one of those gonna count.
What do I have here?
What do I have- what do I have to give you.
Uh-oh
No! No, don't- why- No don't s- why?!
You didn't know that was necessary.
And fire
All right, fair trade I guess?
Suuure
We'll go with that.
Man f- you know, is this something that just like all Swedish people just know, inherently,
They know... if you get trapped in a wo- in the woods
from... a town from the 1940s... and
A alter just whispers to you when you try to take a magical harp
- fire and blood -
You know immediately- Ah! Of course, alright this seems like a fair deal.
Aaahh.. My mom told me about this one.
Ah
Did you enjoy that one guys, you like that one? I bet that was pretty-- I don't know what I did, but okay?
Righty-ho then righty-ho okay, I get it, I get it, I get it.
Okay, I hate this.
This is the worst, that's gonna end very badly for me. I can't go that way apparently-- alright here we go.
We're gonna go outside and we're gonna... play some harp.
Cuz that's what I do.
Oooh! Okay, all right you guys, you guys ready for a ditty? You guys ready for a-a sweet ditty- wait hang on,
Uh, I-I-I get it- I get it, mh- I- what I get it!
Aight, hang on.
Uh Bwooonk
Okay, all right good start, good start- bwooonk
(lovely singing, Mark)
All right, even better started all right- Bwonk bwonk bwoooonk
All right good, we're good and then
Bwonk
NAAwwwaah!
I-I goofed it. Aight, I- hang on. I got started over.
Bwonk bwonk bwonk bwonk bwonk bwonk
BwwOOooonnk~
It's like Legend of Zelda.
Link to the... Ocarina.
You know what I'm saying about?
I think you do. Yeah, I'm a real gamer guys. I loooove to ga--
AAHE!
(Uuuuh ooohhh)
(Good luck Mark)
W-ww..?
Uuuuuuh?
Euhhb?
Excuse you? What did you- are y- were you the tree person? Did you just get up and leave that tree?
Is that- is that something that you guys- No, you're still there. Okay? All right.
Just visiting then I- I suppose.
All right, okay.
Little concerning, but you know, aye, I think it's all right. I'll let bygones be bygones and just don't do it again next time and--
I'll forgive ya, you try it again I'll punch ya in your dick. Oh, I'm on the wrong side. How did I get here? Can I jump?
Huuuhhaaaaahhh-
Ooow my ankles.
That was a horrible error that I committed.
Ah yee.
[gasp]
aaaAAAHH!
What- where- OOOOOH MY GOD! Oooh my god!
Ow, oooowwiee.
Ooowuuuhhhg
Hey! Lady, lady, lady not in front of the children.
Good golly, Jiminy Christmas
You know you are-- you are a few attitudes away from getting a smack, okay?
Don't-- are you the naked lady that was running through the woods, and if you are...
Keep up the good work, I guess? You know, they're really writing about ya. You know your art.
People are-- starting to take it seriously, and I really appreciate that.
Chhuokay
All right
That's a weird music in my brain, right now.
(the mating call, what will he do?)
YYHHOOOOOOOOO
(He repsonds)
Nnaaked lady, I'm over hEEeere!
All right, I gotta go make a call--
YYHOOOOHooooo
YYYHooOOWEEh
I'm right here.
Ah, okay, all right, I get.
Mkay, all right whatever you say.
Alright
euugh
You want to hear? I'll give you a little sweet ditty.
daaaa da da
da da
daaaaa
Did you like it?
Something tells me you didn't like it, alright fine then.
I think I gotta go this way to be able to get to the thing.
Not hundred percent sure, there's these weird walls everywhere.
Uh, nah this is just a shitter.
All right, so where is the magical place? I guess, I could consult the map.
That'd be nice.
I'm very near, I need to cross the river and then take a left.
That's what I need to do.
Mkay, we'll do that 'm gonna do that right now actually.
(distant call)
WOoOWoOyo
I'm getting away from yooou- if you want to catch me, you got to speed up.
Is all I gotta say about that.
Some tells me you might be speeding Uuup.
eugh
Can't tell what's an owl and what's a hooting lady?
Hmm, at least I got what I need so I guess I'll... be on my way then.
Alrighty alrighty alrighty
Okay, all right. I think I got this I think I got this. So I need to play...
Uuuuuuhh
Nnnooope, okay, so I don't know the melody do I?
Aaaaaahhh!
(gears are turnin in that big head of his)
Okay...
Okay, so I gotta find something else. There's gotta be something else here to be able to find-
Oooh...
I thought that was blood on the ground-- to be able to actually find--
The
Melody to play, to be able to know the thing to get the boat to come across from Ruth? Wait no- Rune!
Ruth is dead.
Rune may not be dead yet.
Aight, let me consult a map.
Nah, that's not a map.
[Spooked Mark is spooked again]
Lemme NOT consult a mmhaaap!
Uh-oh, tha- are you naked?
How naked are you?
Extremely is the answer!
[Soft distressed scream]
(scream is returned)
Don't scream in my ear lady. I got a harp if you wanted, I guess.
Kay
Ow ow ow my butt. Why did you bite my butt? Why did you bite my butt?
Stop screaming at me and answer the question. Why'd you bite my butt?
Don't bite my butt.
Oh- I'm dead. I'm so- I'm so dead. I'm so dead. I'm dead. I'm dead I'm dead.
Or not, okay, I guess I'm okay. All right. Everything's good in the world.
Okay, all right, cool, great, all right, so what do I need to do?
something about...
The key- I've already gotten that key.. for rod
storage...
wait, rune.
Okay, wait- up this road to the left. Maybe that's the building that I didn't quite go in.
Just near the clock tower, there's gonna be a-- it's gotta be a something there.
There was also another-- wasn't there another buildin--
aaAAhH!
I don't like that sound out of this.
Ooh, okay, how about this yeah, this one. I couldn't- Oh. Let me in please. I've got the got the magical harp!
Wait
(super focused Mark is focused)
Uh-oh
Uh-oh, uh-oh uh-oh uh-oh uh-oh
[The Uh-ohs continue in a more distressed tone]
[Incoherent stuttering of fear]
Oh god, I'm dead I'm dead I'm dead.
wooOOoHH
Ooh!
AH! Oh ow-
Hey, you are VERY naked. Ow okay, hi, hello lady.
Ah- um- I- uh-oh uh-oh
Well, I died. I did indeed, I was trying to find out a ditty and uh- it did- didn't work- it Diddn't work.
[nervous chuckle]
Okay, whatever you say.
Did I go in here? I don't know if I went in here.
Ooo! I definitely didn't go in here because this-this is horrible.
"Hidden Worlds One:
There's some speculation about whether or not there are other worlds and uh- dimensions
Worlds where the rules of our world do not apply, where reality is spread thin over the branches of--" that word
That I can't pronounce and I'm not even going to try.
Eeuh- oh
[Disgust ensues]
Why?
Eugh
Uh-oh
Hello?
Close that door.
Oh, horrible
Horrible
[Spook]
[More spook]
Euuuughh
Scary baby.
All right, well, this is bad.
What is that?
"She's coming."
Yeah, no kidding. I- I- I'm well aware of that.
"Dead cows found in pen, Svensson had found entire--"
Okay all right, wow.
NAh- don't "Woo Woo" me, please.
I don't want to be Woo Wooed
You gonna leave me alone lady arey-
[gasp]
[smol ambulance noises]
Wow ok-- scary.
Scary
Please leave me alone?
(there's laughter in the background?? More mating calls too)
[Mark responds to the call once again]
Noooooo!
[More forcefully this time] Nooooo!
Nope
Aight, I'm gonna make a run for it.
It's a bad idea, but here we go anyway.
Here we go anyway. Here we go anywhere. Here go anyway--
AH! I don't know where she was but it was very scary.
Yeah, it was so scary. Okay. What's at the top of this hill?
Euuuughhhoooooo
I hate it. I hate everything about it. I hate everything about that.
Everything about that is terrible!
EuGH!
ah
No no no, I can feel flow, I guess.
Aah, ooo, big shoes.
Okay, all right.
ah
So this is the farm yes?
Oh...
The farm where all the cows were very dead.
Neugh, whole bunch of matches. Okay. Good for me.
All right, why did I come in here?
To get trapped and die, that's what I came in here for.
yeesh
Ugh
Yoush
Is there another building here that I can get into?
Hello, you- why are you blocking my way?
Come on. Don't. Oh, wowo girl whoa?
Wowo lady is on roots, and I am NOT doing good. Okay? There's got to be another place to go, right?
What is this? I don't think I've seen this. No. That's the clock tower was that there was that like the storage thing.
Ugh
No that was like...
S- no that was storage okay, so that was a storage there's also like a north..
Door? I want to see what that's about if this is the right way towards it. Nope, this- is this where I just came from?
Also there god damn thumping.
It's weird.
Because I can like tune it out and then it'll just start rushing back.
Oh
Hello, okay.
Ah
"They can see me,"
He-- no kidding the eyes, I've-- I've seen them too--
"Don't come in."
Sorry already inside 'em, sorry.
"Church of Gf- Gjollifars burned blaze. Its escapee from Asarp Santorum captured."
Where are these...?
Newspapers coming from?
Runic writing.
A rune.
Another rune, a bag of runes....
So many runes!
"The Living Mountain: these enormous creatures can be mistaken for
Mountains at first sight, however with a little care, they can be examined a bit closer.
On occasions their enormous eyes are open, and reveal-
[More yelling]
Whooooo
Whoo whoo whoo whoo whoo
Whoo
Whoo whoo whoo
eyy ey yay...
Hey
Why why why why nah- nahh- how about no no no no no no
Nooooooooooooo
No, no no no in fact in fact big NO
Big no on that one. Big bonkin' no--
Hey, it's the windmill!
Aaahhh
Okay alright, what is this? Okay great got this?
Uuuuuuuh
Honestly, no I have not so, I'm very sorry. I cannot help you.
Yeesh. All right, let's find out what's in this building that I had to avoid.
eugh
Do not whoo whoo oh hi oh hi oh hi.
Oh, there's no reason to be in here is.. THERE?
OH Okay, I'm sorry. I'm sorry. I'm sor..I'm very sorry.
Aaaaah
This isn't inconvenient for me.
Whoo
Nothing nothing nothing nothing nothing nothing.
There's nothing here. There's no reason for this- I'm gonna jump over this rock! Evasive jump!
Uggggh, please
Okay, all right we're fine.
LADY!
Pleeease!
Evasive jump, evasive jump.
These evasive jumps aren't working.
Oh?
Woo woo woo woo. I think that's the sound of the all-clear--
Oh, no it is not.
Ooohh.. I'm dead. I'm dead. Oh theres some kind of rune here!
There's a Runey!
Lady! it's a Runy.
Let me live my life!!
I'm gonna die-- all right. You know what? Just kill me, kill me okay, just kill me.
OW
Euugh
Maybe I gotta like sneak, maybe I should be sneaky huh? Maybe I should do that-
Anyway, I'll do that next time because I'm all out of time for this episode.
Thank you everybody so much for watching,
Oh stop shouting in my ear!
Let me know how I did and let me know what you think down the comments below and, uh, as always I will see you...
in the next video.
Bye Bye!
[Outro Time!]